[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Caroline Lamoureux
conseillère municipal de Maurepas
délégué à la démocratie locale bonjour
bonjour alors dans le cadre du budget
participatif communal un circuit
cyclable pour apprendre le vélo aux
enfants a été inauguré en janvier
dernier à Maurepas alors que va
permettre justement cette piste cyclable
au quotidien alors cette piste cyclable
est plus dédiée aux enfants en bas âge
pour apprendre à faire du vélo en toute
sécurité donc les parents peuvent
justement accompagner c'est d'abord les
parents qui accompagnent leurs enfants
c'est pas ouvert aux écoles etc non pas
du tout c'est juste réservé aux parents
qui souhaitent apprendre leurs enfants
comme j'aurais disais tout à l'heure en
toute sécurité et comment ce qu'on peut
justement le circuit est-ce que parce
que dans les écoles maternelles parfois
il y a des petits circuits est-ce que là
il va y avoir des petits stops par
exemple pour apprendre aussi
il a été aménagé un petit circuit avec
des flèches des stops des départs voilà
juste un peu ludique une dimension
sécurité routière finalement dedans tout
à fait avec des stops des raids départ
oui tout à fait alors d'autres projets
ont été sélectionnés justement quels
sont ces autres projets qui seront mis
en place au courant de l'année
les autres projets qui ont été
sélectionnés là on avait par exemple
donc on a vu la voilà le parc canin les
composteurs et le bol au skatepark qui
devrait être inauguré très prochainement
alors le budget participatif est
reconduit c'est un des sur d'autres
projets quels sont les objectifs d'un
budget participatif alors le budget
participatif c'est vraiment
impliquer les morts pasiens dans le bien
vivre leur ville être acteur c'est ça
c'est le maître mot c'est finalement de
de rendre les morts parisiens acteurs de
de leur vie Locale de la vie locale
[Musique]
à la démocratie démocratie locale
démocratie participative démocratie
locale dans la commune de Maurepas
pourquoi faut-il intéresser justement et
faire participer les morts pasiens à la
vie de la commune selon vous
il y a encore quelques années tous ces
budgets participatifs n'étaient pas
ancrés finalement dans les communes en
France pourquoi est-ce que aujourd'hui
on attache une importance justement un
budget participatif alors pour le moral
le premier budget du parti le premier
budget participatif c'était 2016 donc
avec beaucoup beaucoup de grosses
participations et puis bien on s'est dit
qu'il fallait impérativement reconduire
systématiquement tous les ans le budget
participatif et les citoyens de la
commune de Maurepas peuvent donc
participer et déposer un dossier en
ligne sur Maurepas votre quotidien en
poche donc ça c'est l'application ou sur
le site maurepas.fr pourquoi est-il
nécessaire justement de faire participer
ses habitants à la vie de la commune
vous avez indiqué le fait de faire
entendre finalement leur voix est-ce
qu'il y a des thématiques précises
concernant ces projets de budget
participatif alors pour cette année nous
avons retenu trois thèmes donc c'était
la jeunesse c'est à dire qu'il y a on a
dédié euros au 11-18 ans ensuite on a
l'inclusion de des personnes handicapées
ou à mobilier des réduites dans la ville
de Maurepas quelquefois nous on se rend
pas compte qui manque des équipements
donc voilà on tient vraiment à les
impliquer dans la ville et nous avons la
propreté dans la ville qui est un vrai
sujet pour les mortsiens donc on a la
jeunesse l'inclusion l'intégration
finalement mais également
l'environnement il y a une part
d'environnement ce sont trois
thématiques on va pas dire qui manquent
dans la ville de Maurepas mais qui en
tout cas font partie de vos priorités
aussi quelque part tout à fait tout à
fait et puis lors de rencontres avec la
population on entend régulièrement des
petits sujets de propreté justement on
évoque on a évoqué l'écoute des élus
envers les habitants certains citoyens
estiment ne pas être assez écouté par
par les élus d'un territoire de leur
côté les maires élus s’estiment être des
élus de terrain donc ils vont souvent à
la des habitants est-ce que le budget
participatif c'est également cette
échange entre par exemple le Maire
Monsieur garestier et les mortasiens oui
alors évidemment bien sûr pas un échange
direct mais c'est vraiment le moment où
on peut s'exprimer alors qui peut
participer justement à ce dépôt de
dossiers là où on avait évoqué 11 ans je
crois ça peut aller jusqu'à 70 ans nous
avons fait le choix de
donner une enveloppe au 11-18 ans cette
enveloppe est de 30000 euros donc voilà
je pense qu'ils peuvent se lâcher entre
guillemets et puis sinon le reste ça
sera pour l'insertion et la propreté
dans la ville justement pour les jeunes
le les projets en tout cas peuvent être
déposés jusqu'au 12 mars qu'est-ce que
vous attendez justement de cette
jeunesse dans la ville de Maurepas on
attend des choses que nous adultes nous
voyons pas
est-ce que ça peut être parce que vous
avez un skatepark justement il y a déjà
un budget qui a été enfin un projet qui
a été sélectionné pour pour ce skatepark
le parc canin on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure est-ce que c'est justement
centré sur le sport par exemple le sport
de la jeunesse ou est-ce que ça peut
être d'autres d'autres petites choses ça
peut être la culture ça peut être
pourquoi pas une radio pourquoi pas
je sais pas enfin c'est sans limite il
faut juste que ce soit faisable pour les
pour la ville la faisabilité finalement
et pour 2023 les habitants peuvent donc
participer à la vie de la commune une
enveloppe de 100000 euros est réservée
aux projets des morts parisiens comment
les habitants peuvent justement
participer et déposer leurs projets on a
évoqué le site c'est la seule la seule
option on va dire pour déposer le projet
alors évidemment bien sûr pour des
personnes en situation de ne pas pouvoir
déposer sur maurepas.fr ou sur
l'application ils peuvent se rendre
évidemment bien sûr à l'accueil de la
mairie et déposer leurs idées j'aimerais
revenir aussi sur on a parlé de
l'environnement on a parlé de la
jeunesse j'aimerais qu'on parle un petit
peu de l'inclusion justement et de cette
accessibilité aux personnes en situation
de handicap notamment mobilité réduite
sur par exemple les trottoirs l'accès au
bus etc est-ce que ça aussi c'est ce
qu'on peut proposer justement quand on
se rend compte que à un endroit
l'accessibilité
dépourvu justement est-ce qu'on peut
faire appel à un projet pour faire
déposer un projet pardon pour dire voilà
là on en a besoin voilà ça peut être ça
mais ça peut être aussi un parc aménagé
avec des des bancs pour des personnes à
mobilité réduite et après le dépôt des
dossiers des projets comment se passe le
choix du projet justement donc à partir
du moment on a récolté tous les les
projets ont fait une étude de
faisabilité
du budget
parce qu'évidemment bien sûr nous ne
pouvons pas dépasser cette enveloppe et
puis ensuite on remixe tout et on remet
au vote des burepasien il y a une partie
où les élus finalement regardent toute
la faisabilité de tous les projets tout
à fait voilà c'est les marquesiens qui
choisissent toujours avec cette limite
de toute façon c'est l'heure sujet enfin
je sais pas comment le dire
ils sont maître du début à la fin et
vous avez évoqué aussi justement sur sur
ce côté jeune aujourd'hui alors on a les
seniors des fois pas tous qui disent les
jeunes n'ont pas participé parce qu'ils
y connaissent rien etc et les jeunes
disent oui bon nous on est l'avenir
est-ce qu'il y a cet échange justement
intergénérationnel qui se qui se qui
s'opèrent pour justement se mettre en
commun sur des projets et se dire on va
travailler ensemble finalement est-ce
que c'est votre souhait de faire
travailler les jeunes et les moins
évidemment bien sûr ça serait l'idéal
mais pour le moment on est encore un peu
scindé les thèmes puisqu'on a ouvert que
au 11-18 ans
du 12 au c'est déjà ouvert un c'est
jusqu'au 12 mars justement qui peuvent
qui peuvent déposer les projets
entre les générations mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ne pas être pour les années
à venir
en tant que délégué à la démocratie
locale quelles sont vos projets
justement pour 2023 et pour les
prochaines années votre ambition
personnelle en tant que en tant qu'élu à
la démocratie locale
alors mais moi c'est vous en tant que en
tant que lui à la démocratie locale
est-ce que vous avez justement des
projets on a évoqué juste avant la bien
sûr ce que je voudrais c'est des
chantiers des chantiers participatifs où
chaque mort pasien puis se s'impliquer
sur un chantier on a fait là la
plantation de la microforêt et tous les
morpasiens étaient invités à venir
planter un arbre donc c'était pas
c'était pas un sujet démocratie local
mais c'était proche donc finalement même
vous en tant que en tant qu'élu vous
proposez aussi quelque chose au
morpasien de toute façon pour participer
à la vie locale c'est aussi votre
objectif très envie de les impliquer
systématiquement dans tous nos projets
et c'était le mot de la fin et le beau
mot de la fin merci beaucoup Caroline
Lamoureux d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation donc je vais faire un petit
rappel les habitants peuvent déposer les
projets sur le site morpap.fr ou sur
l'appli mort par en poche cette année
vous souhaitez également favoriser les
projets portés sur l'environnement le
développement durable les économies
d'énergie qui sont des thématiques
importantes aujourd'hui pour les
citoyens pour l'environnement et même
pour les élus locaux je rappelle
également que les thématiques sont la
jeunesse l'inclusion la propreté la
jeunesse justement la propreté de la
ville pardon dans la ville et les jeunes
justement de 11 à 18 ans ont auront une
enveloppe de 30 000 euros qui seront
dédiées pour eux merci beaucoup et vous
pouvez revoir cette émission en podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation